Zoe you're in a very interesting film
called blurred it's very atmospheric and
it was filmed in merseyside wasn't it
let tell me about your experience of
making the movie it was brilliant
actually it was I although motor size
one committee I think some of the costs
had to film in quite harsh conditions
they were on a beach in the rain and the
dark whereas I had all my Caesar inside
toes it's very civilized but it was
wonderful it was quite a gritty film and
it's quite dark intense and so it wasn't
a sort of barrel of laughs so every
minute but in terms of the experience in
the acting in there and my my co-actors
and it was fantastic experience you
mentioned you characters oh of course
you play Stephen grams girlfriend did it
don't you he plays a cop who is one of
the two brothers here in the film tell
me about working with Steve and what was
it like playing his girlfriend um it was
actually amazing and he I'm very aware
that he's right next to me here but I
did say it to his face before I can even
work with him I have to say Stephen I
think you're a complete legend because I
just think his especially his promises
in and this is england was so incredible
that they absolutely shaped my
experiences isn't it as an actor looking
at someone else and wanting to emulate
them and so yes it was fantastic working
with him and in fact all the costs were
lovely it was it was a really brilliant
job and everyone kind of really gave it
their all so is it was great it's a very
emotional and sensitive subject as well
I mean how did you approach it I think
you can only really approach it by
somehow trying to find a way of putting
yourself in their shoes and it is hugely
emotional and especially in light of
some of the awful stories that are in
the press at the moment it's quite hard
to watch but when we were filming it
certainly and Stephens very very natural
and we had a bit of time to rehearse
before hands so we got to know each
other quite well and went out for dinner
and felt like we you know we felt like
we sort of had a connection and
and that I think really helped us when
we actually got to the scenes and we had
to sort of pour our hearts out to each
other and what a great cast as well of
British actors isn't there in there yeah
I'm it's the best is rabbi concern may
exclude but that they're fantastic and I
think certainly especially Stephen and
Paul Bethany and Brian Cox are just
brilliant in this film and it's well
worth watching and what's next to you
now Zoe I am well I just finished
yesterday filming along 10 part series
called mr. Selfridge which is going to
be on ITV hopefully I think at the
beginning of next year and it's about
the the man harry said what she started
and who built Selfridges and built it to
come the stores which is today so that's
Karamy different thing that leaders in
it during pittman plays the man who says
so it's been fantastic working with him
he's got all the charisma that you would
need to be a man who built the store
like services he was fantastic and what
can you expect from you in that film I
play brilliantly named character called
Ellen love who is a showgirl and she
becomes M Harry Selfridges mistress and
then the face of Selfridges and then all
sorts of other things happen and what
you kind of think of those kind of
period dramas it's very much in the sort
of line of Downton Abbey and those sort
of things on Titanic isn't it yeah i
think i think that people have a hunger
for that and I think we do them so well
in this country so it's it's fantastic
to be part of and I think this
particular drama is really going to blow
the socks off is ultra glam results are
brilliant and yeah I loved being a part
of it fantastic and after that what can
we look forward to I don't know I don't
know what's next i'm just enjoying this
for the moment really will have good
luck with blood and we look
fortis a mr. Sam who deserves thank you
you